you're doing a remarkable job of staying
level-headed from every one of my staff
is telling me which is is is
unbelievable because you know you live
in such an insulated world when you're a
musician you're maintaining
some sort of normal light so i think
it's beautiful i think one of my one of
my favorite things that a friend of mine
told me was
remember that
everything that people say about you
isn't true whether they say
that you are
horrific
it's not true and if they tell you
you're the best thing ever it's not true
right and
you know i think that that was a big
thing for me i think
i think uh
you know there's a lot of things that i
want to do
and
um there's a lot of music i want to make
things i want to do but i don't
i don't want to make it from a place of
trying to kind of prove myself all the
time to people that
a lot of the time i don't know so i
think
you know we we'd say like sometimes
before the show like everything to
achieve and nothing to prove and that's
kind of where i'm trying to come from
you